earlier this afternoon roughly an hour
before his usual bedtime
bain held a press conference marking the
first year of his presidency it was only
his tenth since taking office fewer than
any of the five presidents before him
he talked about kova the economy voting
rights stuff but joe remember how you
thought not that many people would show
up to vote in the middle of a pandemic
remember how we thought not that many
people were going to show up to vote in
the middle of a pandemic
the highest voter turnout in the history
of the united states of america
well
um i think if in fact no matter how hard
they make it for minorities to vote
i think you're going to see them willing
to stand in line
and and defy the attempt to keep them
from being able to vote
so he just contradicted himself
everybody voted but there was voting
suppression where
but for anyone listening to that voting
rights speech did he say that anyone was
going to be a george wallace or a bull
connor or did he talk about a decision
in history
anybody who listened to the speech
i did not say
that they were going to be george
wallace or
bull connor
i said we're going to have a decision in
history
that is going to be marked just like it
was then you either voted on the side
that didn't make you george wallace or
didn't make you bull connor but if you
did not vote for the voting rights act
back then you were voting with those who
agreed with conor if you notice i
haven't attacked anybody publicly
i guess we're the ones who are hard of
hearing uh you said which side are they
on mr president but you weren't
comparing
joe snapped when someone else pressed
him on that speech but should we go back
and read what he said
no i didn't say that look what i said go
back and read what i said
and tell me
if you think i called
anyone who voted on the side of the
position taken by bull connor that they
were bull connor
and that is an interesting reading of
english you you i assume you got into in
the journalism because you like to write
someone needs his mush
[Laughter]
finally why are reporters so obsessed
with russia
your top foreign policy advisors have
warned that russia is now ready to
attack ukraine
why should the threat of new sanctions
give him pause about russia and ukraine
standing up to russia you said that
russia would be held accountable very
quickly on russia have you determined
whether president putin plans to
invade or move into ukraine
all right
cats
russia russia russia it's still going on
not a freaking word about crime not a
freaking word about the border and all
all these reporters cared about was the
voting bill and russia the two least
important things for almost 99.9 of
americans yeah i agree because when it
started to be about russia i stopped
listening
i'm sorry i was really like
yeah like i get like i get it like
putin's
like i totally totally uh but it was
kind of tough to watch honestly
um and then his argument about the bull
con i think he's like no no no do you
guys you guys seem to think i was
literally saying that these people
literally are bull con
no no he's no he's not around he's i
wasn't saying
that he's literally like you're mistaken
how dumb are you i was like no like
that's not what happened and you know
it's bad
because he kept saying how much longer
am i going to do this yeah
and that happened the i did that the one
only time i went to a soul cycle class
and that's not because it was going well
i couldn't follow the choreography so
then i hate myself like i don't have
enough rhythm for soul cycle like that's
pretty bad so it was really i mean it
didn't was not good it was not good
i might say yeah oh that's true that's
two swear words from the little lady
baker yeah you did baker what were your
impressions of it um and give me
specific gripes yeah i do i think there
were two things that were incredibly
egregious here that he did one was
this idea that uh
again if you're not uh with the voting
rights act and i think that's a
completely misnamed uh piece of
legislation
that uh you know you are essentially
racist that is what he's saying and we
all know it no matter how he tries to
spin this
it's just awful messaging
but i think he firmly believes it for
whatever reason the other thing is the
idea
that somehow
if you don't get this passed the voting
rights act you can call into question
the the legitimacy
of the next election a huge part because
we were enormous any time you questioned
anything that was considered
anti-democratic right and he the
president went there he's done this now
and i think it's it's it's i you know
again i'd like to think of something
funny to say i'm going to leave that to
jaime who by the way is going to be in
boise next week doing a show greg
and um but i think yeah i i can't do it
because i as i was watching this press
conference and he did that
it was very depressing you know what it
was uh just another point on this whole
unity thing how he praised mitt romney i
think he said that he's a straight guy
well he has a lot of kids but this was
the same person that biden said was
going to put blacks back in chains
so this is what happens mitt romney said
the other day that he hasn't talked to
anybody from the white house since
december but
it's it's disingenuous a lot of this
yeah uh i'm a news guy i do news i bring
you news so yeah a couple things here
the turnout in this last election on a
percentage basis with a higher than
we've seen in 120 years right and they
went out did polling they found 94
percent of americans said they were
satisfied because it was easy for them
to vote right so where is that argument
coming from i wrote down man yes yes
absolutely um i wrote down five things
uh five this is not the five bill i only
got two it's going to go quickly his one
failure was not getting republicans into
the game and making things better in
this country namely one thing they're
for where they're not in favor of being
called blue collar yes and racist uh i
have not over promised at all i've
probably outperformed i love that tell
that to the progressives omicron is not
a cause for panic i tell that to the
folks who kind of get the therapeutics
for testing kits russian ukraine i do
think it's a significant story i think
we do need to pay attention to it he
said a minor encouragement i don't know
what that means yes
one thing if it's a minor incursion i
mean vladimir putin may have just gotten
the green light today and we're going to
look at back at this moment think that
was not good for the world right
inflation everything to do with the
supply chain
no mention of the 2 trillion that
congress passed back in march and
nothing to do
with more printing of money in summary i
thought this w went
as expected he did not move the ball
there was very little suggestion that he
was up for changing over the coming year
before midterms other than one thing he
said he's gonna get out there and meet
and talk with the people yeah that's
true i'm scared of that uh damn this is
like being on meet the press yeah i was
feeling you know what i was feeling
pretty sophisticated there for a while
but then i remembered you were here
joe joe do you have five things
any things do you have five any things
in your life
you own five things
i had five i had five quick things
the first one the first one just says
you're doing a great job
these are just things to make me feel
better than i read throughout the show
yeah it's good that's good
his
biden's speaking voice combined with his
content is perfect for a speaker if your
goal is to everyone fall asleep and then
you just quietly tiptoe out of the room
right i was like falling asleep during
most of it i wish there was some way
when he gets all you're a journalist
i wish when he did that there was a
green screen behind him and it could
look like he was in a house yeah and the
press was on the lawn yes
he was just yelling at everyone
i think that would be amazing i don't
know i'm just amazed that they were able
to get that wax figure there so quickly
up next democrats covet solution means
trampling the constitution